[Music]
all right let's go out to Toronto Canada
and talk to Laura the LA what's
up um not much just the usual is it C
you you sound thrilled to be alive is it
freezing in
Canada it actually just sowed so for
those of us in
Tennessee what is that oh is that when
white powdery substances fall from the
sky yeah it hasn't toppled on the ground
yet fully but when I said white powdery
substance Kelly got all excited back
there in the booth it's all hey you did
you did all right so what's up Laura how
can I
help so I'm just going to lead with what
I sent in because otherwise my brain is
all over the place and I don't even know
where to start perfect go for it so the
question is how do I learn to enjoy the
company of
others and so the context is oh that was
the question just hold on that was the
question just by
itself yep that was the question okay
yeah unpack that for me that's that's a
that's a dense
question okay so I'm a high functioning
autistic adult with ADHD okay and I
basically feel like I haven't figured
out how to human yet
okay uh had a miserable upbringing yes
fell under the radar and basically only
got my diagnosis recently
o and essentially socializing feels
painful okay so I don't know how to do
small talk leave a positive impression
or contribute positively to a
conversation and
relationships I can't figure out what I
bring to the table and how to connect
with
people I'm basically fighting years of
mistrust of people in
general and a brain that essentially
ruminates on almost every interaction I
have so I guess the full followup
is I guess how do I as an
adult learn to enjoy social interaction
when I'm so late in the game and
basically when my own brain is
sabotaging my
efforts um man there's a lot there walk
me back what tell me you said childhood
was was pretty hellacious tell me about
it I mean the summary is my dad was a
hoarder okay if he got a diagnosis for
bipolar I'd be surprised that he got the
diagnosis not the bipolar part he
admitted he was an alcoholic and claimed
my mom was also an alcoholic okay
basically as a result of
him and what led to your autism
diagnosis what sent you to go get a
diagnosis or did you do that on your
own I got that on my own recently I mean
did you Google it and figure it out for
yourself or did you sit down with the
psychologist or and do some a battery of
tests it was basically I had to become
an expert on my own because I was sort
of flagged when I was a kid as having
something but they didn't know what it
was and they sort of just gave me like
slapped on a learning disability label
just for the sake of having some sort of
label through schooling okay but it was
never actually properly vetted okay and
so within the last two years I basically
did that myself and had to essentially
sort of figure out okay I think I have
this and this let me go and get tested
because the tests cost money and then
was basically gambling to figure it out
and turns out so far they've agreed with
me okay so you have you have gone to get
test yeah okay for both autism and ADHD
I mean if you ask there might be a
little bit of OCD in there but that's
just my personal opinion and that is
untested okay um adult ADH I mean adult
autism and ADHD often get overlapping
Diagnostics that doesn't surprise me
that doesn't mean you've got two things
wrong with you okay I don't want you to
think I don't want you to think in those
terms like you just went and took your
car in because it was making a noise and
they said well it's the alternator and
the carburetor I don't want you to think
of your mind like that
okay um if it's a true Spectrum Disorder
that's that's going to be a different
conversation so I want to leave that to
an ABA Specialist or to somebody who
works specifically with adult autism
because there's going to be some gaps
there um I'd have to talk to you a long
time um and and like have an in-person
conversation with you but I'll give you
some broader context that might apply
and might also be a challenge to you so
I might not be able to solve all this
issue for you but I at least want to
give you some different perspectives or
some different ways to think about
yourself
okay is that
cool yeah okay so when you say painful
unpack that for me be pretty
specific like interactions with other
people are painful what's where's the
pain where does the where do you
experience the pain and where does that
pain stem
from I mean I would say it starts with
literal physical discomfort okay
where proba Sorry probably everywhere
like even in just having this phone call
it's like no no no where where in your
body where in your body does your chest
get tight does you get that warm feeling
in your stomach do you feel like you
have to go to the bathroom like where
does that sit do you get
headaches it's almost like I just
immediately want to be out of the
situation but it's kind of interesting
now because I'm sort of on ADHD meds
which is new for me and it's sort of
like it's showing me all this anxiety
that I didn't realize I had before okay
almost like that alarm Bell was sort of
just unplugged and now it's sort of been
plugged back in so like right now it's
like heart okay your heart's just beaten
a thousand miles an hour Fair yeah okay
here's why that's important you used a
word that I love and so I want to I want
to just flip this on its head and I want
you to think of your life in particular
your body in this way you grew up in the
home of somebody who struggled mightily
with alcohol maybe two people are they
still
married yep okay um if you grow up in
the home of someone who struggles with
alcohol it's particularly damaging
because that person is absent yet they
are right in front of you and as a kid
it's like grabbing for a ghost it's like
trying to hug somebody that looks like
they're there but they're not really
there it's incredibly traumatic and
disorienting to a
child okay or think of it this way it's
like trying to plug something in in the
dark and you are PL you are just hitting
the wall all around the plug and you
can't seem to plug it in and everyone's
yelling at you to turn the lights on
that's what it feels like right so your
body develops some really profound um
alarm systems when it comes to other
people because the two people on planet
Earth that were supposed to be as
connected as possible to
you were there yet they were gone and
you put on top of that a hoarder
somebody who you had to navigate that a
home that wasn't safe for other people
to visit to come into your parents
probably didn't go out a lot is that
fair there was a lot of social
interaction yep okay so I want you to
think through some of those things and
then I want you to come fast forward all
the way to right now how old are you
right
now 31 okay I want you to consider that
your body is working
perfectly imagine you were dropped in a
bob sled in an olympic competition and
told we're going to shove you off the
edge of this bob sled and you're going
to go to on the
track and we need you to
win your body would a freak out because
I've never been in a bob sled well
you're in a Canada you maybe you have I
grew up in Texas I've never even seen a
bob sled in real life okay so they put
you in a bob sled shove you off the side
of course you're going to wreck it's
going to be
chaotic that that doesn't mean that you
did something wrong that means you were
set off on a roller coaster that you did
not choose and your body's trying to
keep you safe other people people have
been unsafe your whole life and I bet
you got picked on like bloody hell in in
grade school didn't
you see that's maybe another part of
where the problem comes in
okay I mean I was the youngest in my
family and it's kind of like
probably lowest on the totem pole so I
sort of developed this nobody in life
has my back so I will okay mentality
yeah so like I wasn't a bully myself but
sort of good luck bullying me was a
mentality you were just a cornered a
cornered animal your whole
childhood yes that's what help out okay
have you experienced abuse of any
kind like if there was a punch thrown
and didn't hit and make contact to that
count yes if you get hit or if an adult
tries to hurt you yes do you ever
experienced any sexual
abuse not that I would consider
that would other people consider
it debatable okay but only one incident
okay one is
enough one is
enough here's the picture I'm trying to
paint for
you people have never been safe for
you so you're 31 years old and you're
beating yourself
up because your brain's trying to keep
you safe and not engage in small talk
not be around other
people because people who are supposed
to keep you safe hurt you or didn't show
up for you or made you scapegoat on
things and you learn to fight to defend
yourself growing up your whole
life and then you put a potential abuse
on there and that's a different
conversation but you're talking about a
a three decades of your body trying to
protect you from other
people the the the the demon here is
that other people are like oxygen you
have to have them in your life to be
whole and yet your body has rightfully
identified them as the
problem and so if if you
are
the work you have to do and it's not
going to be solved on this short phone
call the work you have to do is to teach
your body over
time that those people were not safe and
by the way if you're still in
relationship with those people I want to
challenge you to end
that end
it because every time you walk back in
that home every time you walk back in
those holiday sessions every time you
reencounter those people um who still
have agency over your
life that alarm system's going to go
off those people systematically hurt you
and took your childhood from
you on the other
side you're going to have to head into
the alarm system when it comes to being
around other people the language you
used and again I'm not going to diagnose
you with anything at all but the
language you us is language I've heard
walking with people who um adults with
um some sort of spectrum
disorder an interaction is very
transactional and that's the way you
described it I don't bring any value I'm
not doing this the right way I need to
be fill in- the blank fill in the blank
fill in the
blank I want you to lose the idea the
best you can of relationship being a
transaction I bring this and they bring
that so that we get
this okay A relationship is not a math
problem instead if you don't like small
talk don't engage in small
talk stand there like your presence is a
gift to a conversation you learning how
to do something that very few people on
Earth know how to do well and that's
listen actually listen to somebody
saying
nothing is an extreme ordinary
gift you can off often enter into a
conversation say nothing or very very
little and have contributed more to the
people in that conversation than anybody
just flapping their
gums an Incredible Gift
and you deserve and desperately need
other people to listen to
you do you have somebody that you trust
a friend a neighbor somebody that um you
know well that you work with possibly a
romantic partner that that knows you
that you can be honest
with I do but I guess I sort of feel
like it's increasingly like I'm dropping
the ball somewhere because I'm sort of
feeling less and less like I can talk to
people why do you feel that way are they
giving you that signal are they telling
you that or is that a story that you're
beginning to tell
yourself
just based on things they've said and
ways they've
acted okay and just little things I mean
like the closest friends I would say
moved away so they're not even
physically able to meet me anymore I
sort of lost them as an
option like I have somebody I can talk
to but they're sort of more increasingly
being like saying things like I'm sort
of trying to play a victim
okay do they know tell your
story I do
okay somebody hears your story and says
that you're trying to be a
victim um I'd probably that that would
be them opting out of my life for a
season if not
forever you've had a pretty gnarly go of
it and I'm 100% convinced you've only
told me 10% 20%
Fair yeah pretty much yeah pretty much I
know you have a very consistent evasive
Cadence that I've heard too too often in
my in my time sitting with
people
um here's here's a way I want you to
reframe it okay and again I want you to
continue seeking care from a counselor
if you don't have one other than the
person you had to pay to go get
psychometric testing I know it's
expensive stay on the line and we're
going to hook you up with better help
for 3 months at least they for free and
at least they can direct you okay um
give you a a ballpark at least look over
your diagnostic stuff and then give you
begin to give you a treatment plan of
some
sort when people are struggle with small
talk often is the case they struggle
with small talk because the conversation
is about them how they feel how they're
not doing how they're worried about how
they're standing how what what their
arms are doing what their hands are
doing are they saying D things or silly
things
or I I want your you to
practice not caring how you stand if
somebody doesn't want to be around you
because you stand weird God bless them
get them out of your
life my friends make fun of how I use my
hands like I talk too much with my hands
and I do kind of weird things with them
when I talk I didn't even notice it
until my friends are making fun of me
one time this is decades ago and they
all love me they don't not hang out with
me because of that and I've learned I
don't care care how I use my hands when
I talk I'm not going to spend effort I
got too many other things in my life I'm
trying to work on so instead of thinking
of a conversation as a performance or as
a transaction I want you to think of a
conversation as Mutual presence one
person with
another sometimes that presence can be
filled up with conversation other times
you may have to practice saying hey tell
me what's going on in your life and you
intentionally not talking about you for
a for a whole conversation just
listening just
listening not comparing not going oh
yeah what happened to me none of that
just listen just listen and when you
feel your heart rate start to beat
faster like you described on this call
or your stomach gets that feeling in it
or I want you to head into that why is
my body trying to protect me oh yeah CU
other people have never been safe but I
think you are to whoever you're talking
with by the way people move away and
it's not your fault they didn't move
because of you they move because life
because of a job or because they got
married or whatever they moved
away but I want you to practice being in
the presence of other people practice
feeling that discomfort and staying
there and practice considering a
conversation not as you put $5 in I'll
put $5 in and that way we'll get $10 no
no no
no not engaging in small talk how's the
weather wow it's cold out here m n I'm
not going to do that how are you tell me
what's going on in your life and and
then just practice
listening these are things that you will
do with a counselor you'll practice the
back and forth you'll practice the
awkward sit the awkward interactions
you'll practice not engaging in small
talk but saying things like hey what
lights you up these days you have a
project at work you're working
on what's the scariest thing that
happened this last
year sometimes I ask those questions
that people think I'm awkward other
times people are so grateful that's fine
I am kind of awkward that's
okay there's a lot in your story Laura
so I want you to continue SE sitting
with a professional counselor
professional psychologist and when you
feel that discomfort relationally your
body's working pretty good because it's
been rough growing
up now the question is are you going to
head into that discomfort and find ways
to teach your body I wasn't okay then I
wasn't safe then I'm all right now
make sure to call
Laura